and beginning our life it was really
hard for us
snowboarding it's just helped me grow as
a person I want to be a person who
people can look up to my name is Johnny
Williams and I'm a part of the First
Nation so working what took place in
residential schools amounts to nothing
short of cultural genocide residential
schools was the government's and the
church's way to stimulate us and control
us the last school closed in 1996 they
weren't allowed to speak their language
or practice any of traditions you're
beaten daily and sexually abused the
Government of Canada sincerely
apologizes and asks the forgiveness of
the Aboriginal peoples of this country
for failing them so the foundling I'm
leaving
the co-op's in which is an Indian
Reservation in Squamish family is a big
part of my life so it's always been one
of top priorities for me the family
really means a lot to him always has he
just turns really fast he was out of
control cuz he was going so fast you do
those yeah yeah no real my grandma she's
very good at giving advice and she's
very understanding so I can talk to her
about really anything she's one of those
people loving the world I don't know
where to be like without her
my father he had a really hard left in
the beginning because he went to
residential school when they came out of
the residential schools they didn't know
how to be parents one way for them to
try and forget was to drink Mike he's a
really aggressive drinker when we were
younger he was a very abusive he used to
hit my mom all the time
where was one time he threw my mom
against a wall and it broke me my sister
locked ourselves in the bathroom and we
stayed there all night
he left us when I was 16 and he sort of
lost contact
I don't know if I'll see my dad again
with alcohol my mom says that it's
probably more likely that I'd be no more
tickets would than others just because
what happened was younger or I don't
drink and I at least try to stay healthy
that's why I'm a part of the first
nation in the war team the team has been
a big part of my life remember when you
broke your wrist I joined the team when
I was seven remember your first day on
this mountain where my first day
remember there's a lot of falling and a
lot of whining they want you to try to
have a good lifestyle they want you to
not turn to do drugs they want to give
opportunities the First Nation kids who
don't really have that kind of money to
be able to do these kind of things I
love snowboarding it's so much fun it's
one of the things I'll probably do until
I die
at first scared the heck outta me but it
really built on ease self-esteem and
brought him to where he is today our
people used to go into the mountains to
do their vision quests where they would
go and sit on the mountain for days
what Johnny's doing with the
snowboarding he's up in the mountains
being out on the land just getting got
the spiritual connection to the land
everything that it provides this
question when I go snowboarding or do
anything outside
I feel calmer I feel like I belong here
I feel it's like where I should be land
is very important for sessions a lot of
First Nations communities are protesting
the big industries and the message
coming from the First Nations youth was
that they're not just going to sit idly
by now and say nothing about all the
destruction happening in our territories
I protest because we have such beautiful
land and animals are just starting to
come back that we haven't had for years
the ecosystem that my family and the
people here how much have been working
so hard to bring back breaks my heart
for people the people who want to do
this there's a really big movement
grandson Johnny is a big part of that
and our community things are like
changing you can see our life was so
hard in beginning was like a bad dream
just a horrible dream
we survived their childhood and nobody
should have to say they survived their
childhood
the children are treasures there are a
gift from God more and more of our young
people have been learning the songs and
the balances my he doesn't know anything
about culture but it's really important
to me it makes me feel really good
because it's Who I am watching dad my
heart just swells with happiness and
pride I love watching him that the
elders in the community that makes them
really really happy they know if there's
hope that our culture is going to
survive
you